one time he had live crabs and I was the
first time that we had live crabs and he
chased us around the house with the
crime we was just terrified and he said
what you cookin I said pork chops and
rice and beans oh that sounds good and I
said anything sounds good to you fat boy
because that was my nickname for him you
know cuz he had gained so much weight in
the last couple of years so I used to
call him fat boy and he would look at me
and saying but you ain't no small
potatoes so I said okay babe I'll see
you later and he said I said okay sighs
I love you inset right back at you and
he drove off that was the last thing
said to me you know right back at you it
just
if
hey
I can never get those images out of my
head and the fact that he was crying out
that he can't breathe and I struggle
with Iseman also so you know for a while
in the beginning when I had when they
are used to have asthma attacks I was
afraid to go to the hospital or the
freeze-up called EMS workers because I
would think he'll figure out who I am
and not help me yeah he had a lot of
run-ins with the police and he didn't
like them and I guess because he was
doing something I was against the law of
course he wouldn't like the cops you
know you know let's keep it real you
know let's bit let it be what it is you
know he was a career criminal you know
he wasn't a bad person he was a good
person you know but he felt that there
wasn't a job out there that was going to
pay him enough to take care of all the
kids yet and you know he was selling
untaxed cigarettes but I didn't think I
was like a major major crime and justice
to us means we get our answers we get
our reforms
and people can stop being brutalized by
the police people getting pictures I
remember like one of our last
conversations he asked me he's like what
you're going to do when I'm gone and I'm
like what do you mean you're not going
anywhere and it's on you you know and
he's like yeah but what are you gonna do
when I'm going I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be here forever and I just brushed
it off yeah this is Erica this is Eric's
oldest daughter this is up here where
she's doing rallies candlelight visuals
and you know all she ship of being an
activist pushed into it anymore he broke
up fights on the street
you wanna see people hurt each other
solidarity man she learns from school
that cops you know call 911 when
see how can you teach your child the
same thing that she was touring up that
the console says that the captions you
know means help when they do come to
help you it's like it its ultimate ends
up in someone dying or someone being
hurt you're gonna keep on fighting we're
gonna keep on doing this we we did this
to let them know that we ain't
forgetting we're never going to forget
not just for every gardener for all the
people of police brutality and now after
jodan stay away from the police don't
have no police contact don't do anything
that would cause the police to say
anything to you one because of who you
are now and two because you're a young
black man just any young black man not
just my son or ever gonna son but just a
young black man
wait for the newspapers um we have a
news conference tomorrow I'm not a today
to say success with your mindset tonight
obviously this music was the upcoming
anniversary I'm I think it said it's
always the same we playing for justice
for my father no amount of money is not
gonna you know um no amount of money is
going to hell I pain so we just pushed
him in search for justice
ultimately I would like to see a second
grand jury so these are
these offices not just family go down
permanently for criminal charge hurry up
that you taste notes in 10 struggling
eat slow
each ready
I mean
she don't really say pop hop no more she
says I regard now that's why I be coming
out everything I love her so you know I
never took his name when we got married
I kept my maiden name and now i'm so
used to Esau gardening now esource
snakes is long gone i'm no longer that
person anymore I'm a whole different
person my father's last words not just I
can't breathe but when he said this
stops today what gets me up every day it
was to give him that voice I have to be
that boy it's being that he's no longer
here and I feel like it's my duty being
that I'm the oldest and i miss rose
and this is what he will want me to do
you
they ripped me off of him laid him on
the ground full of bullet holes and
cuffed him but he didn't hurt him like
he was going somewhere